[Música]
mi padre era cirujano vascular llegaba
tarde de operar de noche una profesión
muy estresante como todos se imaginan y
una de sus pasiones era salir a caminar
por la ciudad nos invitaba a mis
hermanos y a mí a quien quisiera
acompañarlos a mí me gustaba mucho ir
con él porque era un modo de escucharlo
escuchar lo que pensaba cómo veía las
cosas y una de las cosas que me decía
era que convenía siempre recorrer las
ciudades de noche había menos autos
menos gente y uno podría realmente
apreciar el espacio de otra manera me
decía hace un día viajas tener la suerte
para conocer otras ciudades
resérvate un rato para salir tarde de la
noche vas a poder verlas de otra manera
y me decía otra cosa que volvió a mi
cabeza bastante tiempo después cuando
empecé a estudiar arquitectura y pensé
sobre alguna de las cosas que él me
decía me decía en mi próxima vida
quisiera ser arquitecto o después de mi
jubilación quisiera estudiar la
arquitectura según el estado de ánimo
del momento
es curioso porque decía esto él decía
que quería ser arquitecto porque su arte
y él
de algún modo percibía la cirugía como
un arte un arte que requiere enfrentarse
una situación nueva cada vez y mucha
manualidad y más la cirugía vascular
hacer trasplantes de venas arterias
etcétera pero él decía que su arte
estaba destinado a perecer que la vida a
los seres humanos inevitablemente son
finitas por lo cual por perfecta que
hubiera quedado una obra que le hubiera
hecho poco tiempo después ya no estaría
y él me decía en cambio los arquitectos
hacen obras que perduran de algún modo
creo que esas palabras que las olvidé
por completo créanme durante muchísimos
años y volvieron después cuando ya
estaba abrazando la profesión creo que
quedaron en mi cabeza y por algo
volvieron claro la ciudad que recorría
en aquel momento era esta era una ciudad
muy diferente a lo que es montevideo y
yo soy montevideano más allá que pasó
también mucho tiempo en la pedrera una
ciudad amable de pequeña escala una
ciudad donde aprendí a manejarme como
alguno de ustedes aprendió a manejarse
en su ciudad eso que hablaba al área de
las ficciones aprendemos las conocemos
en la ciudad una luz verde es para
seguir una roja para parar la
arquitectura aprendemos la arquitectura
también las puertas las ventanas la
lógica que tienen uno ya sabe como los
niños hoy el celular uno ya sabe
manejarse con la arquitectura a prender
las luces apagarlas etcétera yo hubiera
querido que esa ciudad nunca cambiará
como cada uno de ustedes probablemente
hubieran querido que su barrio su casa
de la niñez nunca cambiará yo hubiera
querido que aquello fuera eterno que mis
padres siempre estuvieran que mi padre
también estuviera hoy aquí hubiera
querido
sin duda que mis abuelos y todo
continuará tal cual estaba porque esa de
algún modo era la ilusión que todo niño
tiene
no comprende el tiempo no comprende los
cambios yo no tenía ni idea donde
estábamos no tenía ni idea que en
realidad éramos parte de una pequeña
esfera una pequeñísima esfera que gira
sobre sí misma a 1700 kilómetros por
hora y que se traslada alrededor de una
bola encendida a ciento ciento 107 mil
kilómetros por hora pero que además esa
bola encendida pequeñísima respecto a
otras que hay en un espacio
forma parte de algo mucho mayor que la
vía láctea que a su vez está dentro de
un universo y que la vía láctea junto
con las otras estrellas se expanden y se
están moviendo que nada está quieto que
nada se detiene que todo está en
movimiento
no tenía ni idea de todo eso pero que no
sólo se mueve sino que se transforma
constantemente y que esa transformación
constante es lo que permite que hoy
estemos acá como también veíamos a orar
y anteriormente y explicaba
pero tampoco tenía ni idea que esa
monstruosidad que se podría abrir al
comprender el espacio exterior también
era de idéntica profundidad hacia lo
minúsculo hacia lo microscópico esta es
una imagen de una glándula humana pero
podría hacer tantas otras imágenes de
los microscópicos y empezaba a
comprender cuando empezaba a entender
estas cosas hasta qué punto es
apasionante la percepción
en tanto es el único medio de
conocimiento que tenemos del mundo que
los rodea y sin embargo es engañosa nos
da todos los datos que precisamos pero
debemos develar los nunca son los datos
suficientes y que fantástica que es la
mente humana que con su capacidad de
generar instrumental y de entender y
generar hipótesis y practicarlas y
fallar y volver a entender logró
comprender todas estas cosas que
estábamos viendo
y profesión mi disciplina la
arquitectura el urbanismo está en una
escala intermedia ante otras cosas el
mundo que habitamos está en una escala
intermedia que es la que percibe el niño
que con la que aprendemos orientarnos
que es la que describimos de algún modo
cuando pensamos en la ciudad pero es muy
diferente si la pensamos por ejemplo a
esta otra dimensión
hoy ya podríamos decir una dimensión
perfectamente aprensivo le por el ser
humano hace 100 150 años esto no era así
y hoy los voy a generar en avión las
imágenes satelitales son cosas frecuente
así
montevideo aquí por ejemplo buenos aires
la salida del río uruguay al río de la
plata fíjense lo que es montevideo
fíjense la bahía o buenos aires
en realidad podrían ser dos rocas si uno
llegara de algún modo de otro lado y
pudiera volver a describir y entender lo
que está viendo y ese es un ejercicio
que les propongo hacer esto podrían
llegar a ser dos rocas gigantes talladas
no sabríamos y construidas sobre una
capa verde natural o si socavadas pero
perfectamente podrían ser dos rocas o
simplemente lugares que existían y que
colonizamos al habitar ahora son dos
rocas singulares son rocas artificiales
eso lo sabemos y también sabemos que
debemos aprender a manejarnos con ella
porque estas rocas específicamente son
portadoras de mucha de la información
que arar y decía también anteriormente
respecto a la ficción que es la
construcción humana debemos controlar la
expansión de esas rocas porque sabemos
que se consumen muchísima energía y
consume territorio que es finito en el
planeta
debemos a su vez si queremos controlar
esa expansión y la población aumenta
poder renovarla esa roca si no se
renueva internamente
están en grandes problemas porque el
único modo sería expandirse pero también
esas rocas condensan la información de
la cultura la cultura humana está en
esas rocas los edificios los símbolos
los edificios religiosos políticos los
espacios públicos allí está la mayor
densidad de cultura humana si nos
acercamos un poco más empezamos a
comprender ya un poquito más y esa roca
no es tan pareja como parece en realidad
esa roca está conformada por piedras
ortogonales porque ortogonales bueno
porque la tecnología la geometría el
avance de la cultura
nos ha llevado a hacerla de esa manera
porque es el modo de mejor manejarlas
el objetivo original de la formación de
esa roca generar cavidades en realidad
son rocas cavernosas y el objetivo final
que tienen son esas cavidades en donde
transcurre la vida de cada uno de
nosotros la sumatoria de esas cavidades
en vertical son edificios la sumatoria
de esas cavidades en horizontal
separadas a una cierta distancia que la
ficción que el hombre es capaz de
construir ese espacio público es calle
de esas cavidades o esos edificios en
torno a espacios un poco más amplio
conforman plazas en definitiva si
concebimos la ciudad sí y a cierta
distancia del tiempo y del espacio es
interesante empezar a verla de otra
manera interesan esas cavidades y la
asociación de esas cavidades piensen
ustedes que dos de los libros bestseller
que vienen del campo de la ciencia del
campo de la historia hablan de una breve
historia una breve historia del tiempo
stephen hopkins que hace el esfuerzo de
sintetizar en muy poco en muy poco texto
lo que ha sido el devenir de la ciencia
en especial en la construcción
del espacio y del tiempo el otro que
recién veíamos una reseña de animales a
dioses de su al hadari tiene por
subtítulo el sugerente nombre de breve
historia de la humanidad breve historia
del tiempo breve historia de la
humanidad la ciencia y la historia la
ciencia y la sociología la ciencia y la
cultura están comprendiendo lo breve de
nuestra historia en el planeta si es que
logramos continuarla en el interior de
esas cavidades todos cambios ahí no
tenemos duda todo cambio constante y una
persona se muda y viene otra con sus
cajas sus retratos sus afectos sus
cuadros que va a poner en las paredes
sus discos su música y lo va a inundar
de la vida de cada uno del ser de cada
uno del yo de cada uno y ahí todo cambia
por ahora minuto a minuto según una
familia viene otra en la cavidad en el
interior en el individuo como en todos
nosotros todo cambia también cambia y
esto es independiente de la clase
sociales es independiente de las
construcciones culturales esto es la
esencia humana el cambiar
el alterar orden es claro cuando vamos
al espacio exterior las cosas diferentes
porque estas construcciones son
construcciones sólidas rígidas y no es
sencillo de cambiarlas no es sencillo de
alterar ese orden y ahí se manifiestan
las aspiraciones humanas las más
primitivas aspiraciones humanas que nos
acompañan al día de hoy inalterada de
aquel momento esta foto por ejemplo es
una imagen a contraluz un atardecer
atravesar jiminián o una ciudad de la
toscana en italia que construyó esta
silueta en la época medieval porque
porque cada una de las familias querida
de algún modo tener su destaque
construir su skyline marcar el perfil de
su ciudad que había construido ahí nada
simplemente casas de huéspedes miradores
lo que había era el anhelo del ser
humano que acompañe a la construcción de
las ciudades y la arquitectura de vencer
la gravedad ir para arriba piensa en las
catedrales góticas muy finas y muy
verticales y deben ser el tiempo a
través de monolitos que queden esto que
es tan primitivo y que de algún modo me
remitía lo que decía mi padre la
arquitectura la ciudad
están destinadas a permanecer no es tan
diferente esa silueta que vimos recién
de sanz jiminián o edad media y
podríamos tener otra los menhires
etcétera a esta manhattan
en el siglo 21 simplemente otra
tecnología a otra época otro momento
pero el mismo anhelo de vencer la
gravedad de vencer el tiempo y de algún
modo de marcar la ciudad el skyline
montevideo y permítanme que me refiero a
montevideo podría ser cualquier otra
ciudad población de vivo y es una ciudad
importante entre uruguay valdría para
cualquier otra no es ajena a esta lógica
el palacio salvo el edificio ciudadela
hay tantos otros edificios que están ahí
de algún modo también responden a esta
lógica de la que estamos hablando en el
interior de cada una de esas ventanitas
y todas las que uno pudiera tener la
infinidad de cavidades que despliegan la
individualidad de cada uno de nosotros
viviendo ya adentro una cosa
constantemente cambiante mutante como
objetos que se mueven con cosas que van
y vienen en cuadros que cambian música
sonido en el exterior una cosa
relativamente más rígida y que parece
bastante como impenetrable digamos no
pero sin embargo en el nivel cero de
esas cavidades es que transcurren
nuestras vidas en esa apertura en esos
espacios públicos y que transcurre en
nuestra vida ese es el escenario
es el escenario por excelencia de la
vida humana
y la atención
entre el cambio
y el patrimonio entre el cambio y la
permanencia entre el futuro y
salvaguardar lo que hemos aprendido y lo
que nos han legado está presente en la
esencia de la arquitectura en la esencia
de la ciudad también la necesidad de no
expandirla por lo cual es imprescindible
resolver esa situación es claro de que
la historia de la ciudad condensa como
decía anteriormente los códigos de algún
modo el saber que ha acumulado la
civilización por lo cual es sin duda muy
importante preservar los y cuidarlos de
algún modo legar los también a la
generación siguiente sin embargo
también es claro que ese patrimonio de
díaz se construye que en algún momento
se hizo y que hay que rehacer lo que hay
que reinventarlo y que hay que construir
los edificios la ciudad los espacios
públicos que nos representen en el siglo
21 y en el siglo 22 que lleguemos a
nuestras futuras generaciones ninguna
sociedad puede vivir simplemente de
cuidar lo que recibe sería una visión
sin duda como muy cortoplacista no fue
así que se hizo nuestro uruguay no fue
así que se hizo nuestras ciudades si
entonces es necesario de algún modo y es
complejo y de eso se trata y negar la
complejidad del mundo contemporáneo
sin duda sería perecer en el intento la
complejidad es esencia al mundo
contemporáneo lograr equilibrar estas
dos cosas y aquí quiero detenerme
mínimamente
este es el espacio cívico por excelencia
de uruguay no digo de montevideo de
uruguay en la plaza independencia
monumento a artigas enfrente están los
edificios más representativos es la
plaza por excelencia
hay un elemento singular que es el
palacio salvo que sin duda destaca sobre
el resto es la gran esquina de la ciudad
la plaza con 18 de julio y por eso hay
un elemento que lo destaca de esa manera
es claro que escapa a la a la línea a la
cota superior de los edificios que la
rodean
hoy podríamos construir esto
lo aceptaríamos socialmente no se
llenarían las redes sociales al otro día
que apareciera un proyecto de estas
características queriendo destacar de
esta manera no se llenaría las redes
sociales de críticas y de pedidos
desesperados porque frenen esa obra
podríamos hacerlo podríamos construirlo
como sociedad estaríamos preparados para
hacerlo esto que más allá de su belleza
porque a ciertas caras la belleza menos
importa hay un arquitecto rem koolhaas
un holandés que habla de los edificios
gran scala bikinis le llama que dice
pasado cierto límite los edificios valen
por su impacto valen mucho más por lo
que generan en la memoria por por lo que
generan el skyline que por su propia
belleza podríamos construir esto
y si no lo hubiéramos construido
tendríamos la imagen de montevideo que
de algún modo nos representa a la manera
que nos representa pero tomen en cuenta
inclusive que estos edificios que están
cerca en determinado momento tomaron
como referencia al palacio salvo y
debieron hacerse más bajos que el
palacio salvo un debate famoso que
recuerdo que lo vi en la década del 80
entre guillermo gómez platero y marian
ahora en aquel momento que encarnaba
algún modo la lucha por la valoración
del patrimonio en donde se discutía si
este edificio podría ser más alto que el
palacio salvo y se decidió que no que no
podía ser más alto que nada en la ciudad
podría ser más alto que palacio salvo
por lo cual esos edificios hoy serían
así
creo que
no digo que fuera mejor ni peor pero sin
duda sería una ciudad diferente son como
esos acontecimientos que pasan en la
vida de cada uno que uno piensa que era
pasado si tal o cual otra cosa sería
diferente quizás esto sería lo que
valoraríamos etcétera pero me animo a
decir por lo menos que no sería mejor a
lo sumo diferente en lo personal
prefiero aquello que inclusive nos
permite recordar a la ciudad de la
manera que la recordamos pero podríamos
pensar algo parecido obviamente con la
torre de antel la polémica que se generó
en torno a eso todo la conocemos cómo se
hizo etcétera pero si cuestionamos la
torre de antel perfectamente deberíamos
hacer lo mismo con el palacio de la luz
por ejemplo sería acaso mejor esa imagen
que ésta tendríamos una ciudad mejor
habría una diferencia cualitativa
por lo menos es claro que tendríamos un
recorte en el cielo diferente y una
ciudad que sigue manteniendo un cierto
perfil del cual cuesta despegarse hoy la
rambla sur que decir de la rambla sur
'hemos se han hecho se han escrito ríos
de tintas recientemente sobre la rama
sur porque gracias a una construcción
que se hizo en la década del 30 tenemos
esta acceso a la ciudad vieja que si no
no podríamos estaríamos en medio de un
atolladero de autos porque no podríamos
circular desde la ciudad vieja a la zona
este que la zona más poblada esto se
construyó para haber entre 30 y 40
casillas en la década del 30 y es en
realidad lo que aún hoy le sigue
salvando los problemas a la ciudad la
rambla sur esta propuesta como
patrimonio para la unesco este
y se comió varias playas hubiera pasado
si nos hubiera hecho
sin duda tendríamos un patrimonio menos
que proponer a la unesco que es el de la
rambla tendríamos algunas playas más que
hoy no quisiéramos tocar por lo cual no
podríamos construir esa rambla
tendríamos una situación diferente
probablemente más trabada y estaríamos
enfrentado a eso de ver cómo
solucionamos la entrada y salida de la
ciudad pero esto
lo podríamos llevar a todos los momentos
y todas las épocas y creo que es
importante tomar conciencia de hasta qué
punto el patrimonio se construye y hasta
qué punto si dejamos de hacerlo
estaremos llegando una ciudad bastante
más pobre que la que hemos recibido qué
hubiera pasado si hoy alguien pensara en
el punto más destacado de la bahía de
montevideo su el cerro al costado de la
bahía del punto más destacado de la
ciudad el único accidente natural más o
menos relevante que tiene la ciudad si
alguien propusiera hacer una
construcción maciza de muros de ventanas
pequeñas de muros pesados una
construcción militar yo creo que por lo
menos habría despertado otra que fake
news
esta polémica profunda y bastante
alboroto que habrá pasado si no se ha
construido no sé cómo sería el cerro
quizás sería mejor
en tanto oír ha estado menos antropizado
pero lo que sí es claro que no
tendríamos el escudo patrio que hoy
tenemos en el cual justamente eso es uno
de nuestros principales símbolos yo para
terminar quiero contarles una anécdota
que quiero que resume mucho esto de la
necesidad de estar abierto al cambio de
estar abierto a construir la ciudad a
legar patrimonio a construir patrimonio
futuro
el 14 de septiembre de 1977 había una
gente acá de la zona en la cantina del
club en una noche muy de mucha niebla y
dentro de la niebla yo estaban mirando
la televisión una serie set cetera de
repente ven una luz sobre la playa que
probablemente se llamará la playa sur no
sabemos cuál era el nombre y quise
averiguar entre la gente más antigua la
pedrea y nadie ni siquiera recuerda el
nombre que tenía esa playa
y el sonido de una bocina de barco como
parecía como algo encajando y como
despidiéndose al otro día el 15 de
septiembre de 1977 amaneció con esta
imagen en la playa que a partir de
algunos años posteriores sería la playa
del barco en el qatar que había
encallado la noche anterior producto de
la niebla e inmediatamente imagínense si
aquella imagen que vimos en la primera
conferencia de una botellita de plástico
en la arena significaba este
preocupación lo que sería un barco
entero encallado en la arena
permaneciendo ahí imagínense la
preocupación que eso generaba
evidentemente en el verano del 78
empezaron los intentos de llevarlo de
nuevo al océano con los remolcadores que
venían del puerto de montevideo y hacían
su mejor intento de sacarlo un momento
que entendieron que es un imposible por
lo menos era mucho más caro que dejar el
barco donde estaba en ese momento
decidieron desguazarlo sacarle todo lo
que pudiera ser vendible y simplemente
dejarlo
con una imagen bastante fuerte diría por
lo menos
bastante incómoda de tener una cosa de
este tamaño encallada en la playa sur
claro al tiempo
la playa pasó a llamarse en la plaza del
barco
el salitre empezó conjuntamente con las
olas a trabajar el barco
de algún modo lo transformó en un
monumento
en la playa que hicieron de esta playa
una playa singular y hubo toda una
propuesta urbanización inversión y si
hubo de algún modo una singularidad una
enorme cantidad de costas oceánicas que
sin embargo no tenían algo que le diera
un carácter específico
la plaza del barco se transformó en una
de las principales playas de rocha
el monumento aquel accidente aquel
problema que el evento se transformó en
un monumento
que le da singularidad y nombre a la
playa en este momento con con mi pareja
con andrea tenemos un encargo difícil
que estamos tratando de pensar hace
tiempo y es que nuestros hijos luca y
que ahora que pasaron toda su infancia
en la pedrera y en la playa del barco
nos pidieron que diseñaremos un tatuaje
geométrico que de algún modo contemplará
el barco
el barco está desapareciendo el barco
dentro de algunos años y se lo dijimos
van a venir con sus hijos y dirán esta
plaza se llama la del barco porque aquí
alguna vez hubo los restos de un barco
encallado quieren de algún modo llevarlo
en su piel porque de algún modo son la
historia que todos quisiéramos que no
cambiara aquello que en algún momento
fue un accidente
aquello que en algún momento fue un
problema y después se transformó en el
monumento identificatorio
es claro
que la ciudad debe continuar la ciudad
debe continuar porque yo creo que
ninguna generación puede sentirse con la
arrogancia de pensar que fue la última
de pensar que aquella ciudad que conoció
de niño quizás caminando con su padre de
la mano diciéndole la arquitectura está
destinada a permanecer y entonces debe
no cambiar creo que ninguna generación
puede sentirse con la relevancia de
decir la ciudad llegó hasta a mí hasta
como yo la conocí y así debe quedar
porque además nadie extraña lo que no
conocido solo con no extraño los
tranvías mi abuela me hablaba de
tranvías y de cosas que yo no conocí y
si hubiera parado ahí la ciudad no sería
la que yo reivindico como no será la que
reivindiquen mis hijos ni mi nietos
la ciudad debe continuar porque ninguna
generación se puede sentir con la
arrogancia de decir hasta acá llegó pero
sobre todo porque todas las generaciones
tienen derecho a construir su futuro y
su patrimonio muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]